it's a pleasure to introduce the
solution very selfish problem for many
of us in the world actually extremely
well trained neuroscientists go to
machine learning and it's impossible
losing to neuroscience wonderful minds
and possible declines impossible to hire
people in this field to do the
day-to-day work vivid analysis and
modeling and theory but the wonderful
solution of someone going off and doing
you know groundbreaking work and machine
learning and applying it to neuroscience
hope to meet you
all right the stop is being recorded all
right so it's an honor to be here so
today I'm going to talk about inferring
single trial neural population dynamics
using sequential autoencoders and one of
the pleasures of going near to last is
that so many of the preliminary concepts
have been already discussed and debated
and introduced so that's a nice thing
let me at the outset acknowledge some
collaborators in particular Chaffin
Pandor Nath who is now an assistant
professor at Emory he's really done the
the really hard and careful work of
applying this technique to a number of
datasets and honestly we couldn't have
done it without I'm also an O'Shea who's
a I guess a postdoc in krishna's lab and
jasmine collins who is a PhD student
here and she was instrumental in helping
us vet this technique on a bunch of
simulated examples where we understand
what the ground truth and we kind of
know what's going on alright so i
learned yesterday that we have some
differing opinions about Mars so I
changed my outline so we're gonna
introduce the three levels of Mars
analysis and for the first hour we're
going to talk about computation
and in the second our love dive into the
algorithms okay and then finally the
last ever be implementation but you may
or may not know actually there is a
level 4 for the aficionados all right ok
no for real what we're actually going to
talk about is what has been bandied
about is a dynamical systems hypothesis
and this is used in a certain group of
people who think about motor cortex and
prefrontal cortex and I'll mode I'll
define what we mean by that what I mean
by this and how it motivates a data
analysis technique ok so it leads to
this technique which we call L fads and
I'll give a bunch of results and that
are basically improved decoding on
single trials we can study the single
trial dynamics we can use this technique
to sort of stitch together datasets that
are recorded on different days and maybe
the different days data can
synergistically improve the the fits and
so we might talk if we have enough time
about inferring inputs to neural
circuits using this technique and also
oscillations which seem to have come up
a couple of times ok so this is really a
single talk with a few sub pieces and
depending on the level of engagement
during the talk we may or may not end up
finishing ok so the hypothesis is that
let me see if I can
great so the hypothesis is neural
computation is explained by dent
dynamics Oh Dino the evidence for
dynamics in the brain is overwhelming so
the question is what do we mean when we
say that neural computation is explained
by dynamics and there's a recent
literature about trying to define what
we might call a low dimensional subspace
in which some abstract dynamics are
occurring and that these abstract
dynamics are what these neural circuits
are sort of actually doing but so what
do we mean by this let's see if we can
explain it a little bit more so we have
our neural circuit here that we're going
to study and we look at the spikes of
each neuron for K neurons and so we just
think of the population state whatever
you actually studying here is this
population state which is just the bend
spike accounts of this neural circuit in
some kind of operation during some kind
of behavior okay and then we we have a
sort of dynamic by just bending the
spikes and moving that the those bend
spikes through time and so just to put a
couple of different examples more
recently in the literature we have for
example low dimensional dynamics in C
elegans low dimensional dynamics for
contextual integration in the prefrontal
cortex and also rotatory dynamics in
motor cortex when it comes to explaining
reaches so this is going this data set
is going to figure a large into the talk
I'm giving today so let's jump in here
and well this is a I think the third
time this slide has been thrown up by
different speakers so we have a neural
state space and we're going to take
these bend spikes and we imagine that
there is a dynamics that is on some low
dimensional in this case it looks like a
subspace but low dimensional manifold
and we think of this as the state of the
circuit and that unlike for example the
way that people think about the
feed-forward networks and object
recognition we're not thinking about
representations here so much as dynamics
is what we're highlighting and so yeah
for example with an animal that is
making sort of complicated reaches
through this maze like structure and
here are some example reaches here in
the XY plane you get this dynamics and
so that's that's what we're about we're
trying to understand this
and so what do I mean when I say
dynamical systems I mean that this lower
dimensional state has an initial
condition and that there is a dynamics
that is dependent on the circuitry of
that area and that you have a vector
field and you just integrate and at
different conditions do different things
right so in this world of an autonomous
system which is pretty simplified we
have F we have the dynamics that we'd
like to learn and we have an initial
condition sort of a per trial per
condition initial condition that we'd
like to learn and that would completely
describe these dynamics there's a single
there so that's right so that is
something that we will address but for
the majority of the talk I'll be looking
at the the autonomous case while fully
acknowledging that this is a simplified
view okay and so that's what I mean no
autonomous means no input yeah the full
so the the just to give you the full
story
the elf adds architecture also has
inputs that that can be inferred so that
we can do the non autonomous case but
what we discovered in review is that if
introducing the inputs early causes
extreme doubts about what the dynamics
are doing and so I introduce it now
later so that there can be no confusion
about the dynamics explaining what what
the results that you see move it but
they don't assign a very small part of
the neurons
hey euros out of who knows Menominee
which are all connected to each other
that's right
how can you what what justifies the
assumption of that these key neurons
have autonomous dynamics so I'm not sure
it's entirely justified a priority but
when one models these data with an
autonomous system one finds a very good
match to the data and so knowing the
rest of the Neth basically yes
on top of yes essentially and on top of
this the sort of very widely observed
result that the dynamics of protect
potentially due to the simplicity of the
behavioral or the experimental set up
the the dimensionality of the dynamics
tends to be much lower than the number
of neurons in the area so essentially it
is just like saying that there's what is
the main okay which actually justifies
this stuff that would be a theoretical
question that I won't answer so you know
I'm briefly mentioned this yesterday
which is that if you increase the number
of you of you know you record from 200
but you say what happens it happens all
right
it keeps getting better and better you
get the 100 and then this sort of
saturates you know and by 200 you're not
actually getting any more information
out of the state it's a brain state so
is it selling your death in fact there's
a lot of redundancy right right yeah
we're fact you're a fact there's too
much or done you know that's a part of
surprising amount that's right it's
shocking in fact given the experimental
set up that's right and as was mentioned
previously more recent recordings under
the carandini lab are demonstrating very
very high dimensional data in v1 okay so
so this whole world this whole story
about dynamical systems explaining for
example motor cortical data makes sense
for conditioned average data and so
that's really what's been done the
condition averaging has been used to
sort of get rid of some of the spiking
noise and perhaps some of the other very
ability that's in these circuits so the
question is well what happens when you
and this is indeed the challenge that
we're addressing today what happens when
you try to do this type of analysis on
single trials
well if here I've showed you this this
rotatory plane which was found using a
Tec technique called JP CA if you run
the JP CA technique on single trial data
now in this case we've taken a Utah
array so I think in this maybe maybe
even two so about 200 channels or so
it's a disaster it just doesn't work it
doesn't make any sense on single trials
you can't you can't see through the
noise of it and so that's what we're
going to do and so now I think it's
useful to sort of outline what we've
been talking about here with respect to
this dynamical systems hypothesis in and
of its own right but this hypothesis
also motivates a data analysis technique
and that's what that's what L feds is L
feds is an embodiment of this hypothesis
and so let's let's now operationalize
this hypothesis into a data analysis
technique so we have here are spikes
through time and so I'm really thinking
now of of high dimensional spike trains
that are being recorded I'm really
thinking towards the future of what
neuroscience will be in for many labs
the future is now so we think of these
spikes as having a sort of each neuron
has a firing rate right and you can get
the firing rate by it by condition
averaging but you could imagine there's
this thing called it's an abstraction
but this thing called an instantaneous
firing rate for each neuron and again we
further imagine that these firing rates
are composed of a lower dimensional set
of temporal factors right okay so what
now what we're arguing is that this all
comes from a dynamical system that's
nonlinear and that what you'd really
like to find is the code or the initial
condition to generate the data that
you've observed right and that is this
is the so alphas is a sequential auto
encoder this is the decoder or
generative model of L feds
okay so as was brought up there's a
there's a architectural tweak to
tolerate or allow non autonomous
dynamical systems we'll get there at the
end but for now we're focusing on this
system okay so
we're gonna use an RNN and just to
briefly define what we mean when I show
this sort of top-down looking at the
brain kind of graphic what I really mean
is a set of state space of G and that
it's recurrently connected and iterating
through time and that these these
connections can be learned to generate
the dynamics that we're interested in
and that after training this dynamics is
fixed and it's implemented through the
recurrent weights of the network that's
what we mean here and so how do we get
from a generator to our observed spiking
activity our bins that's right it's just
a it's just an RNN that's with right
it's a tied weights deep network that's
it yeah okay so well we're gonna have a
little bit of stacking here to get from
the generator RNN up to the observed
spiking and well it's going to be the
latent state what I call the factors
before up to some inferred firing rates
so this is just a linear transformation
and then there's an exponential
non-linearity here to keep so these are
sort of like Poisson rates that then
explain spike counts this is all the
sort of emissions model here is very
standard setup for describing spike
counts okay so we're just gonna run the
generator and then there's this
feed-forward set of layers to explain
our spike counts and so on and so forth
okay and that's all summarized here
we're gonna fit I realize this may be
belaboring it but I just want to make
sure everyone understands we're gonna
fit our data that's high dimensional
with multiple trials we're gonna get
these abstract inferred instantaneous
firing rates from a set of low
dimensional factors this factors are low
dimensional because that set as a
parameter of the network there's
actually nothing about this technique
that is dependent on having a low
dimensional system so that's also
thinking towards the future and that the
generator now spits all this out on a
per time step basis
and the code is the initial condition
there's a whole other story of this is a
variational auto encoder it's actually a
statistical model but that's not central
to the points that I want to make today
so I'm going to skip over it
so you you will we will learn those
weights that's right but then they are
fixed all I mean to say there's this
very standard train the system and then
use the system for inference that's
that's all I meant to say so essentially
I mean there was another picture that I
wasn't going the long time ago it tries
to model this sequence like this within
hidden Markov mode and which is similar
in a sense but there are assumed some
stochasticity in the in the dynamics and
essentially the states are discrete
discretized in some sense we're talking
about discrete dynamics and but it's
self organized and learned and of course
there we we don't need a really assume
that it's not an autonomous because
there's always we can couple the the
rest of the system with some sort of
noise right so they sort of meet you
halfway here it's first differences
basically if the the the analogous
version would be a common filter right
you have a continuous hidden state and
you have a Gaussian distribution over
each iteration of that state and but
that that whole system is linear in this
case it's nonlinear and that's really
the big the big one here so and also
can't be loaded so fine so but this is
this is where the smooth high
dimensional dynamic it's it's possible
that maybe I'm reinventing something
here the same picture of it okay so the
other thing is the noise model is a
little different I'm asserting a
deterministic dynamics once you know
that the deterministic sees me the
probabilistic code for the initial
condition that the fee for dynamics are
deterministic excuse me the recurrent
dynamics are deterministic it's learned
it'll be learned from the data no I
don't understand is it like this
essentially a complete
cleek basically everything connected to
everything i said yes so with some
weight to go to zero yeah so in this
case we're using what's called a gated
recurrent unit so it's a standard
architecture in the deep learning
community and it basically is an altar
all connected set it's a complicated
architects are it's all all connected
and wait to go to do well who's to say
maybe if you had yeah it could it could
possibly be that way but but the idea is
that you have this randomly initialized
network to begin with and then those
random initializations are trained via
optimization pressure to spit out the
data that it's seen during training
States I just random this is randomized
the entire thing is randomly initialized
alright it's just to start that's what
it can do oh how do I go I see yes no
I'm so you're talking about the initial
state here so that is the encoder
portion and so it's just gonna be the
same machinery so we have here so this
is now an auto encoder all right let me
just pull that up here so you put in
your trials your bin spikes that goes
through a different RNN and at each time
point it's it's sort of sucking up the
the bin spikes of that time point
creating now a code through time because
an RNN has a latent state and then that
latent state is read out as an initial
condition all right so this is really
just a big auto encoder and it's
actually an enormous bottleneck here
well let me say it's a really tight
bottleneck right we're trying to explain
a sort of if you will n by T amount of
data with a G dimensional code right
that you it's like a like a pinball or
something right you'll really need the
usual states from in it yeah that's
right we read out and we read out
linearly exactly okay so this is the
whole model so it's deep learning
methodologies we have a negative log
likelihood loss based on Poisson
distribution of the
of the bin spikes and so we could ask
well what's interesting let's say we ran
this right let's say we train this well
what's the interesting part of this well
the fire rates are interesting that's
sort of the first thing you would look
at it's basically saying I'm gonna
deliver some abstract instantaneous rate
that I believe on single trials is going
to be extremely informative or hopefully
more informative than the binned spikes
okay
you also have this set of low
dimensional factors which is a low
dimensional representation of your data
and this is sort of in analogy to the
rotatory dynamics that we showed in the
motor cortical example we have the
draped train dynamical system here so if
you have the wit to do it and I have to
admit I don't yet you could study this
system as a sort of encapsulation of a
system that can generate the data that
you are interested in studying and then
finally the initial conditions right
this is the code for your entire you get
one per trial and so you could study
those and and and make statements about
those all right
isn't there in this regard our cowboy
so yeah the factors will be temporal but
they're a linear readout it's just the
tip the factors are a linear a low
dimensional linear readout of the RNN
state so it goes back to here we go
these are the factors they're just a
linear read out without any recurrent
dynamic themselves of this generator
state there did their temporal
dependencies only as a function of the
temporal dependence of the recurrent
neural network there just immediately
reading out the neural you have a neural
network that's right
and we will so we'll jump right to it
okay so the final statement here if all
of those details were a little too in
the weeds let me just say that what is
alpha alpha there's a means of sort of
denoising your data but unlike for
example just passing a Gaussian filter
over a spike train alphas is different
it knows like in order to be noise if
you will the spikes of a single trial a
single spike in a single dimension of a
single trial it's using all of the data
of all of your trials to do that okay
and so that's embedded in the network
through the weights and that's what
makes it smart and powerful okay because
it speaks your data so let's jump right
to a vet ik example no I don't see why
not
I don't see why it wouldn't be a
guarantee I guess I'm saying is how
expressive is it so for the data we've
studied it's it's very powerful
I can I can imagine scenarios where it
might break so a scenario where it might
break is if you tried to study v1 data
right so v1 data it's well people have
talked about and hat in the last few
days all of these other dynamics going
on in v1 but it's pretty well understood
that v1 is driven strongly by a sensor
system and so there's no in the setup
there is no input so there's no way that
this model is going to function well
there my thinking on the matter is that
even though you know vision is like the
paradigm of neuroscience actually most
of the brain is going to be a better fit
here because the recurrency is it's just
it's ubiquitous in everywhere and you
don't really have to motivate it too
hard do we need to try a structural no
you do not need a trial structure that's
right it would definitely help to have a
trial structure to understand what's
going on but you definitely don't need
one okay so let's just start with a very
simple example the Lorenz attractor it's
a three dimensional system and it's sort
of visualized in its three dimensional
state space there so this is a ground
truth example we're good and now you
just see this system run it's three
dimensions through time so we're gonna
make up some some fake neurons right so
this is like the factors and we're gonna
make up this have this redundant
representation by just taking random
projections of these three dimensions
and now we can just artificially spica
phi it using a poisson process okay so
when we do that now we get a bunch of
trials that are just spikes can we go
back and learn this why can we can we
have learned the system basically and so
let me just introduce it very quickly a
couple of other techniques there is a
recent technique vvl GP by ma'aming park
GP FA by byron you and John Cunningham
and colleagues and P FLDS believe this
is also John Cunningham these these are
recent in the last year to two years
this is mid-2000s and so anyways when we
reconvene up all these models and when
we reconstruct you can see just by eye
that elf ads is doing a much better job
and that turning it into a Poisson
process is not
very noisy channel in some sense so
there's some some rate the rate either
change very slowly or some other
organization of the red otherwise it's
just an hmm again I your hidden
dynamical systems and you see it
stochastic observationally and all you
can do is reconstruct it within some
precision so well I like so this may be
an example of a well-known genre of
tools but I can tell you based on
comparing it to other techniques that
this one performs better and that's sort
of as much as I can tell you and the
reason why we're motivating these
examples is because when we come to the
neural data you can lose your flooring
very quickly right you don't know what
you're looking at and then you know you
think for example Hawkins embeddings
here and Sonny Liston you can take
enough points and you can actually
reconstruct the dynamics but these two
point is at least twice the
dimensionality of supplements now or D
plus one another D plus one yeah and and
in this case it's easy because they're
low dimensional system once you have a
much higher dimensional structure it
becomes very missing okay so let's go to
the next synthetic example now we have a
hundred dimensional RN n that's randomly
initialized to have chaotic behavior
this thing is a beast
okay and so we're gonna do the same
story we have here the underlying rates
of the system we spiked if we normalize
them and then spica phi it and I
challenge anyone to see this in that
right so the variance is not relevant
it's a complicated system and we just do
the same thing we train the system up on
lots and lots of trials and we compare
it to other techniques and again you can
you don't even need to quantitate it you
can just see by eye that elephant is
doing significantly better at this task
the other seems to be low pass those
around
yeah so yeah so in men is an assumption
of the gpf a model is that there's a
time constant that you end up smoothing
things by and so on and so forth
one crime one run this is one run that's
right
so so well so we trained on I don't
remember call it two to four thousand
trials right we sort of picked the high
end of what is done in experiments and
now you're just seeing the output of a
single trial and I would say that pretty
much most of those trials are going to
look like this one sorry so wait trials
you just mean that that in an amount of
time that's - Nikki just a random choice
yep that's right that's right you
initialize randomly a few thousand times
the length of this test but so yeah like
this times 4,000 is the data set so this
on I mean jeez a couple hours so on real
data sets I'm not gonna lie this has all
the benefits and all of the detriments
of deep learning techniques hold on to
your hats if you don't know how to tune
hyper parameters if you have a lot of
data you're gonna have to chug through
it but well as you said earlier and yeah
in the talk deep learning is popular
precisely because even if it's slow at
least it can handle these type of data
so it will it will live and die by the
same criticisms in this case I don't
remember I think it might have been
order 50 or a hundred units yeah so
that's it's an interesting question I
didn't do that particular study I would
like to think that it would improve my
guess is what's really going to improve
it is more data yeah right exactly so I
don't remember the number of factors I
would say these ballpark numbers are
basically right 100 dimension for the
generator forty 25 to 40 dimensions for
the factors and then the readouts are
obviously dictated by the
is there a simple mapping at all of the
RNN to actual connectivity yeah that's a
very lengthy ugly degenerate and yeah my
thinking my thinking is that I don't
know that you would actually I to think
when I was putting these aren't ends
together that I was actually building
brain circuits and I don't believe that
anymore I believe that what I'm doing is
providing a rich dynamical framework for
building dynamics and there are there
are yet to these so I guess the general
question is it's great predictor but is
it a testable theory about the brain I
think there are plenty of things that
will be generated as testable theories
but am i building am i this actually is
another question that came up in the
review am i how seriously should you
take the connectome of this network and
I think the answer is honestly not at
all except for insights that you might
derive from studying it right if that is
to say if you know motor cortex
generates a particular dynamics and
you've made a system that can also
generate that dynamics and you've done
it robustly then there should be
something that's similar but then but
the nature of the connectivity could be
completely different because the nature
of the if you will then the the neural
compute fabric is totally different
supposed to do something like this you
may find something so we're gonna
there's a lot of talk left-right yeah so
you can do it
I bet to me that's just it's a
trainability issue right I've no doubt
it would work just fine if you're
willing to struggle through training is
I don't ya know steam engines okay so
let's move on to some real data then and
this is data collected by mark
Churchland and Matt Kaufman and again
I'm gonna come back to this data set
thing so called the maze data set for
the purposes of the basically the animal
had to make reaches right and the
purpose of the maze they had their own
agenda but for the sake of this
conversation it's just a way to instruct
a bunch of different types of reaches
okay all right so now we're going to
look apply elf ads to neural data and so
let's just take a peek at this is for
example two arrays and at motor cortex
m1 and then premotor cortex both of
these are associated in in movement so
if you take a Gaussian filter at a
single trial and just pass it over
each channel well you have a parameter
which is the width of that Gaussian
filter and so this is that would be this
is this is not alpha this is Gaussian
filter over each Channel and as you vary
sort of the width this is sort of the
best you can do with that right so this
is sort of what Gaussian filtering does
to your data okay now this is what L
feds thinks of your data it was just
totally nuts to me like I when I first
saw this I was very surprised not the
least of which is because oscillations
pop out literally everywhere okay so I
went through some kind of like the
stages of grief the first was like
denial is that really there and then I
kind of ignored it for a while and then
I started testing it oh it's really
there and I'm sort of at the acceptance
phase right now yeah so this is a is
about a second of data I'll get into all
of that here so here we have two more
examples because it actually highlights
I've just used this red line to
differentiate mode m1 from PMD so here
is the data single trial another single
trial these are the rates the inferred
rates and these are the inferred factors
all right so you can sort of see what
this system thinks about that data and
you can see some sort of some slower
type of dynamics there this is by the
way in a movement so the reach is
prepare the reach it's instructed go Q
go right so here is actually during
during the region so what was the range
of frequencies that
yeah so it's really stuff that's really
fast 2 to 15 to 40 all right yes yeah
exactly and so it's maybe we'll get to
some analysis of that at the end okay so
I guess the point of this talk is to
sort is a little bit of a show-and-tell
to sort of verify or validate the
methods so the first thing I want to say
is that everything I'm showing here
here's on cross validated data there's
no there's no training data on these
pages the second is that what about what
validate means it's sort of a strange
thing when you don't have a ground truth
right so the best I can do is show you
examples and then correlate the the the
denoise stuff to kinematic variables
right two things that we that we've
studied so that's what I'm gonna do and
we do a lot of it but the first we're
going to take a look at some some PSD
itches the the bread and butter of
electrophysiology so these are the each
colors just a different condition I've
shown the smooth spikes this is sort of
what people do but you can sort of
average elf fads rates and you can
average GPA rates as well and so we
let's compare those but on single trials
well if you try to do a psdh on single
trial it's it doesn't it's an it's an
almost nonsensical it doesn't make any
sense well you can do that with GPA you
start to get some structure and with elf
feds you see very tight structure so for
example this this yellow condition has a
lot of variation in the initial
condition if you will i sort of revealed
some bias there in the early part of the
trial and then it sort of tightens up
and so on and we can just look at a
bunch of these and you can see just whoa
sorry
maybe he's a little too high resolution
so there's a lag that I'm not contending
okay so you can just see that the
structure on single trials here is sort
of very stereotyped and there's you
could have really two two experiences
here one is like wow this is like that's
real structure and you've pulled out on
on single trial the other experience as
well that is so stereotyped that maybe
all you've really done is show the the
sort of the average right so so what we
would do then is show you that let's
regress to kinematics so this is the
animal had made these moves and so we
recorded the kinematics and you can
regress the firing rates to those
kinematics so if you do that with just
smoothing I here I'm just showing a
bunch of trials right for one condition
two condition three condition so you can
see what it looks like with smooth
spikes if you do gpf a it's a little
better but you have to squint to see
that it's a little better and this is
this is really this is the
state-of-the-art single trial analysis
beforehand and now when you do on elf
Ed's you can see that whatever it is
about those rates it's really useful for
decoding kinematics and you can quantify
this here this is the r-squared between
the decoded kinematics and the actual
kinematics and the main point is that
here in blue and L feds it's just much
much better and critically as a function
of the number of neurons we did a whole
bunch of different elf Ed's runs where
you change the amount of neurons use you
can just see that for example gpf a two
hundred units is about as good as L feds
at fifty units or so GPA is a Gaussian
process factor analysis so it's
basically you do factor analysis and
then you have a Gaussian process model
for smoothing are you regressing to the
factors
or the year-old yeah it's a great
question and it in the different cases I
do different ones in this case it's
regression of the factors thank you for
the regression of the factors to the to
the kinematics okay so we talked about
that the code here is an initial
condition right for it for each one of
these trials so here I've shown you just
a sample of reaches that the monkey made
as a function of the reach angle right
it's just give you some sort of
breakdown of that and if we do a TC
visualization of the initial conditions
you can see that the TC visualization is
two-dimensional because it's
three-dimensional with a rotation in
there there's this TC visualization
recapitulates the structure of the
Reach's so this says that the
information about the reach is encoded
in the initial condition okay so now
let's come back to the the motivating
challenge which was can we do one of
these types of state space dynamic plots
except on single trials and just to
remind you the single trial version was
really super noisy well when we do that
now instead of doing it doing this
analysis on smooth spikes we do the jpc
a jpg a is the optimization to get the
rotatory plain we project our data into
that but now we use the inferred firing
rates what we see is actually extremely
clean and you can see that on single
trials that these that these dynamics
are showing up
and so everyone loved the movie you can
just take a quick look at that so this
is if you just do smooth spikes there's
some structure there and this is if you
do J PCA on the elf ads rates and so
there you go
okay so yep the single trial case the
the initial states the the starting
point for the motion is much more
variable than it was in the average
cases so you were averaging the starting
point as well as the entire dynamics
yeah so the starting point is just the
initial point of the so everything gets
averaged including the starting point
yes so then for the initial conditions
that data code comes out of this encoder
right that is the code of the whole
system and it's going to have it's going
to have the variability it has assumed
we assumed that it got it right or it
got that maybe too strong we assumed it
encoded some structure into it so
another statement that you've learned
the dynamics of a particular region on
in this particular for this particular
behavior of reaching is that you should
be able to hold out a particular type of
condition and it your system should
generalize across that type of condition
so what we did here is we took all these
reach conditions and we made we just
chopped it up into a bunch of bins if it
resulted in 19 different sets of
conditions so what we trained is 19
different alphas models with one
condition this reach angle held out left
out right and then you say well if I
really believe the dynamics then I
should be able to generalize to that
reach angle even if I didn't train on it
and in fact so that's just schema
tightening that and in fact when you run
now J PCA on those models on the held
out conditions you see a very similar
structure and the initial conditions are
nicely correlated especially this first
one the held out vs. when it was trained
okay so now we're going to transition to
another elf ads architecture that is
going to we're gonna address
multi-session data uh which has somehow
taken on the term stitching stitching
together different data okay so a
practical reality of systems
neuroscience is that there are limited
measurements and even as we move forward
into this new this new era people are
still recording with single units
petrodes Mew probes V probes etc and
wouldn't you like to increase the
statistical power of your datasets in
some intelligent way what we're going to
propose that elf ads can do this for you
nevertheless when when researcher goes
in electrophysiologic physiologist goes
in and studies area on day 1 day 2 day 4
day 50 they believe they're studying the
same system I'm assuming some some the
animals learned right so it's it the
same way here you believe you're
studying these same underlying dynamics
even if the day to day you take these
neurons one day and this set of neurons
the other day and so forth
so we're gonna use alpha elf ads to try
to make sense of this alright so this is
data from Eric Troutman and analysis
from Dan O'Shea who did a ton of work to
get this right so now we just have a
sinner outreach task okay it's a it's
still Center outreach it still reaches
but it's simply a simplified data set
and and in particular we're gonna use I
guess they're called mu probes or V
probes these are 24 channel linear
probes that go in and these two
gentlemen recorded a lot and so I
exaggerated the example here just to
show you I wouldn't it be nice to
combine the 45 sessions that they did on
each on different days right
okay so in terms of I don't want to
belabor this but in terms of the
recordings they recorded over this say
six millimeters in the precentral gyrus
area and so if we just look at some of
the heterogeneity of the sessions this
is sort of target on set and reach I
guess of yeah exactly go queue and move
you just see that there's there's a
variability right in the representation
you only have 24 units here that's right
that's right yes exactly
inserted sort of these experiments take
a few hours and you just 44 days yep
okay so here is just all 45 I guess it's
45 I don't remember 44 45 for the upward
reach I just showed you single trials
from all the different sessions just to
just to give you some of that
variability okay so now we have to
augment this architecture and the key is
that we're gonna have sort of readout
matrices for each individual day but the
core architecture the generative portion
the R and n is going to be the same for
all all sessions and the idea is that if
there's any for example the art the the
units are different so you need to have
a little linear mapping from the
generator to those different units on
day by day so the way we do that is we
have let's say we have two this is one
through s but 1 & 2 right so you're
gonna have a different input input
matrix for that session that then goes
through the common architecture of the
encoder and the generator and then back
out to its individual matrix to get the
the random mapping and for another
session it's the same story unique make
input matrix common architecture unique
output matrix when is the shared
architecture learned is it learned with
the same day yeah so at for every so now
when you when you batch up your data for
a given batch you have to pick a session
and then what you do is you say that you
just set it up cleverly so that during
the training when you do back prop you
get gradients for everything but you
only apply the gradients to for this
session say to the to its readout matrix
it's read in matrix
should use this and the intern in the
model internals and then for a different
day you exclude the the read in and read
out matrices right so that's how you do
it
what is this pre session readin so
that's a matrix that's also just plastic
weights that's it yeah so you have to be
able to drive the system appropriately
for this new data set so it's much more
intuitive and easy to understand why you
need to read out matrix but there's a
there's a sort of if you will similar
story on the input side the dynamics
change significantly if you for example
a pen session one session two and then
use that as the training data that's an
interesting thing to try what that so
it's a funny thing because that breaks
sort of the the single trial nosov it
even though we're doing some hack with
single trial here because now you get
single transfer session s but you can
read out single trials that didn't
happen for the other sessions but what
you're suggesting is some have even more
radical which is just tack sessions
single trials together right yeah
exactly so we didn't do that so what
important things are shared almost
everything so the entire generative
architectures is shared this what we
built here is basically yeah exactly so
what we're saying is you're allowed it
an individual day is allowed to drive
the system differently and to read out
and to read out differently but it still
has to drive through the same dynamics
that's right and so by virtue of the
fact that we have different input Maps
here you might think well geez that's
really dangerous because you could
really have s different dynamics this is
a very these generators are powerful it
could totally learn something nutty
right and on each individual day and so
when I show you this plot this is again
just a low dimensional representation of
these data now instead of single I've
been showing you lines of single trials
here I'm showing you each line is the
condition average of a particular
session for forgiving reach so let's
just focus on the orange there let's
just call that the upwards reach right
that's the conditioned average dynamics
for session 1 session 2 so you can see
that the system found a common
underlying dynamics that explained all
of those different sessions of data
despite the heterogeneity that was shown
for that upward reach in the early setup
so under par this is highly discretized
highly discretized I'm not in the number
of colors of this yeah that's the
difference that's the different reaches
that's the reach conditions ok
so these are just I just showed you this
is just a three dimensional view and
then I put it forward here so yeah
that's a condition independence so you
just sort of average over everything and
that tends to be orthogonal to the J PCA
rotation ok so now we can look at this
at single trials so here's the hand
reaches to begin with it turns out that
orange was down and to those two you're
right but if we can do this is going to
be kinematic decodes again right and the
idea is to demonstrate that the
additional power that's stitching
together these datasets provided so
smooth GP FA is a pattern here
oh no I'm sorry this is single try this
is you Gaussian smooth the spikes yeah
so now with single session elf pads it's
better but you know you only had 24
channels here so this is still a little
wonky right on the individual trial if
you go that is to say you train elf adds
on one session only right and now when
you do multi session it really cleans up
the factors here right it really cleans
up and I just want to highlight this
difference is large and this difference
this improvement is also large and you
can quantify that and you can say that
the R squared again R squared between
the inferred kinematics and the actual
kinematics you can see that for every
single dataset the improved there was an
improvement by combining the datasets in
this way this is motor codec so you have
stigmatism some of the cells are going
to must I explain is right so you're
gonna have sort of pretty unique
combinations for different to decreases
there's no symmetry there maybe that's
how this it's working if you were to
take system at the hydration system zoom
Li you wouldn't recover the same head
directions in each separate sessions you
might have to rotate it to get it to
match so the way that I interpret it I'm
not entirely sure what what you're
saying but to the degree I understood
the theory I understood it what's going
on here is that if you will the the
Wiggles have correlations across
sessions right and so if you have any
sort of optimization on simplicity which
we do there's regular additions in there
to keep the system as simple as possible
then yeah the system should try to
convert make us the optimization should
try to make a simpler generator that
takes advantage of correlations and the
Wiggles across sessions yeah as a
biologist I want to ask
would work between animals the Zi Chen
will have its own internal dynamical
system I would write I would guess it's
the same between animal this is at the
very very top of the list of things that
I want to do next because there's a few
technical problems I'm not sure for
example a linear readout is going to get
it done between animals but one would
but one would imagine that some kind of
topological preserving but you know
warping and shifting and things like
that you might still have the same
dynamics aside from that type of look
one is a little emotional what is very
high dimension again you're going to
have different K different cells of
course in different animals and what's
going to relate the dynamics that well
the belief is that if there's a common
dynamic and all that's being done is
saved just let's take the easy case of
just rotations and shears and things
then you each other so it's an open
question and you know if I was going to
put money I say this is gonna work
honestly this is all these I think so
yeah yes yeah so for that for these be
probes know what we've done promoter
work is with these Utah raisin where we
always have promoter and m1o hand is the
actual kinematic reaches that the animal
made so yeah we're taking the neural
data and decoding just because the
animal has variations yeah
because you before you said you trained
it with like yeah so you know I want to
get back to you on this but I'm pretty
sure the answer is order two to three
hundred fewer trials but and then you're
increasing the number of trials but
you're also shifting the yeah so you
combining you've sort of you're
combining your data but you're not
entirely certain it's gonna work out
okay so so the first answer is going to
be if you did analysis X before do L
feds first and then do analysis X right
that's sort of my is not a very
satisfying answer to a theoretician but
I think to people who are in the data
all day long if you can get like
dramatically better decodes to kinematic
variables or to any variables that you
study the chances of you making
meaningful science scientific statements
is going to be I think dramatically
improved so how much can be done in real
time for a BCI that's another thing that
is second on the list that can actually
maybe third but but yeah so there's a
version of there's a version of this so
this is like a common smoother you I
didn't go into the details but you get
you get to the the method gets to see
the entire trial and you have to disable
that and it will be through the power
will be decreased because of it but
real-time is nice right okay so I'm
gonna push on I don't really know how
much time we have but I'm getting
towards the end okay great okay great so
we have here I'm gonna show you some
movies and now what I realized that last
night in preparing this in the final
preparation that I was missing a slide
here so I showed you these really nice
representations where all the different
days data looked really similar to each
other
and that's in the stitched model what I
don't have the slide for unfortunately
is to show you that the individual elf
ads model is one model per session is it
does better than GP FA but it's not
overwhelmingly good so there was really
an improvement there so in this in this
movie I want to try to
whoa that's definitely not where I
wanted to go sorry okay so we go forward
does anyone know how to pause on keynote
that's what I'm asking
spacebar no check it out of this bleep
yeah okay I mean let me do that it's
worth it's worth it a hot SEC here
oh geez okay you know I'm just gonna
play that I'm just gonna play it and
we'll see what happens
all right so the first thing I'm gonna
show you is G PFA another technique a
single session and singly exactly a
single dot is a single trial the color
is the reach direction so what I want
you to see here is that these low
dimensional projections are not
particularly inspiring that's G PFA now
for a single session in L fads same
thing single trial and you see now you
see start to see more structure but
again it didn't have that nice rosette
structure that's a hallmark of GJ PCA
now we do a single trial excuse me a
single session of L fads and you can see
you've got the nest rotation here
because why not so by combining the data
I have to get through this movie
otherwise I can't stop it so by
combining the data you you see in the
movie you got a really clean up
representation on the single trials so
now the next step is here all of the
English every single session 44 or 42 of
them just to fit them so this is G PFA
again not much structure so this is what
I really wanted to highlight elf ads on
different models yeah it's got structure
but it didn't find that commonality by
combining and stitching so yeah okay
there and now finally the stitched model
for all the different sessions and you
can just see like it's like it's just
whoa there's lots of structure there and
again I want to come back and just
highlight because the stereotyped nature
of this is so strong that you would
think that you've lost information but I
just want to highlight that these
kinematic readouts are dramatically
improved by doing this so so it seems
that smooth gpf exit eyes that don't
really as human eye and excel try to
extract the dynamics so I move we're
wondering when you're using a pretty
powerful and
Thanks network whereas you could try for
linear dynamics or other other methods
yeah it's like it's taste right I mean
look at this so there first off there
are P okay so maybe it's uninterpretable
that that's a reasonable criticism right
oh my take is that we know the brain is
nonlinear we know that the brain has
contextual e different dynamics so just
embrace it and well they've done that is
this cool a bit yes I mean this
trajectory doesn't look like you need a
hundred dimensional Network does it I
would come back to I'm building for the
future here right I mean I I guess I'm
just not sympathetic to the complaint
I mean sure go ahead you could swap in a
linear model into the generator you
could do it but we already know what's
gonna happen it's gonna do reasonable
job on linear things so you can do
piecewise linear that's right in German
and Scott Scott Linderman has been
pushing this forward in the last year or
two in that case there are more
difficult optimization aspects to it
though because there's a discretization
in the latent stage that's how you're
progressing sorry look this is the point
time and we're evolving and it may well
be that there will be decoding
techniques to look at your complex the
chaotic Network and be able to read out
things from it that'll give us an
understanding so I don't I don't think
we should use that as a criterion right
now so I'm well I guess what I would say
is concretely what does elf ads give you
that right on the table is useful the
inferred rates the factors the initial
conditions and what I'll show you in the
last segment of the talk is these
inferred inputs in the non autonomous
case I totally disagree with that that
is a fair comparison
but another fair comparison is just take
whichever model you think is the best
one and give it the best crack that you
can to do its job and that's what I've
done here we
at time we talked to all the author's to
make those models work as best as
possible so it's just a that's another
fair thing to do my criticism is about
they're good sure we can swap you the
code is available if you want to swap in
a linear system feel free it's there
seriously we can take your denims and
and I believe that there's not enough
there I mean anything a linear predictor
which is changing in time but auto
regressive age of M as we call it so
I've shown you that we can decode ground
truth of a chaotic Arnon and in in
simulated case I've shown you that we
can do better decodes I know I don't
know what else I can do right what else
do you want is it great conversation I'm
gonna move on so we can finish up good
okay okay so behaviorally relevant
inputs from single trials the last part
of this talk is somehow the most
speculative but I also think very
interesting so the motivation is we all
record from areas we meaning my
experimental collaborators where you
know the system is getting inputs from
all over the place right so this
assumption that we're modeling not
modeling autonomous dynamical systems is
obviously incorrect and what we've shown
is that for places like the motor cortex
in certain behavioral paradigms it is
not grossly wrong so but there's caveats
for example if I build a system and I
allow the variability of the trials to
be stuffed into an initial condition or
into an input now all of a sudden
there's a identifiability problem right
that's an issue
another issue is if there's noise and I
let like in a common filter innovation I
just let that noise come in and to make
fit the data better then I don't know
what it can I interpret that you know I
have to be very careful right so but
we're in it we're in a world where we
know these inputs are coming into the
systems we study let's just see let's
try it and see what happens
okay so what that means practically is
changing this model to include an input
you
and so now fully specifying this system
requires learning the dynamics and
initial condition and you and I just
want to point out explicitly that if the
complexity of you is not limited in some
way either low dimensional or the
complexity of the Wiggles this is no
constraint on your system I'm not I get
that I acknowledge it and so will show
you what I hope are systems where we've
constrained it enough so now the ALF
adds architecture has to be updated I'm
going to be very brief here but
basically the generator now needs a
controller it needs another system to
tell it when an input it comes in right
and so that controller is going to spit
out a U of T at every time step right
and it gets to see the input data
through some encoders and it also gets
to see what the generator outputs right
so if you if you're familiar with common
filter innovation this is very similar
except that and it's except that it's
pushed into the generator so the
inferred input literally is input to the
generator and without really taking some
real time to explain this that's just
going to have to suffice okay so so mu
is so this is so it's another
statistical code so there's a there's a
mean and distributed a standard degree
distribution on noise yeah in sort of
keeping with the variational auto
encoder architecture okay so now instead
of thinking I guess another way to said
is before we're saying we have one
vector that explains a time series of
data now there's this sort of if you
will allow me a strange outer product
you have this initial condition that's
that's for one time point but a high
dimensional vector and you have this one
by T vector or maybe low dimensional by
T vector and it's the common
these two things that define the
dynamics of a single trial okay
so let's again fall back to synthetic
example here we have excuse me I jumped
way too far
okay we're using build an integrator
take an RNN use back prop build an
integrator it takes white noise and it
outputs a bounded integration two plus
one or minus one in green is the target
in red is the output of the system after
its trained so now of course we want to
say can we identify the the input right
so after trade this is what the spikes
look like after training I've just shown
you five of the instantaneous rates you
can see it's doing a pretty good job and
here at first sort of an average example
in in black is the actual input to this
system and the inferred input by elf ads
is in cyan and I would argue if that if
this was the performance that was given
for biological data people could
actually use this this would be a
meaningful signal to study okay and so
just to this is a point three r-squared
example that I showed you over here okay
so now let's move to some data and here
Sergei Savitsky actually created a task
that is perfectly set up for this so
animal is going it's a BMI task animal
is going to it's too strong we just
explained it there's a cursor then the
animal has to reach towards the target
that pops on the screen and so for many
reaches it's just unperturbed but on
occasion the the update screen updates
the location randomly of the target so
there's jump right and jump left so we
have three conditions here recording
from m1 and PMD again and now there's
ups and downs and so sorry there's up
reaches and downwards riches and the
perturbation associated perturbations
okay it gives us six conditions four of
which are perturbed in ways that are
unpredictable to the animal alright so
here is an unproductive my PMD m1 PMD
unperturbed perturb left perturb right I
can make up stories but I can't see
anything in that personally I'm single
tries this is the this is the hash okay
so when we run out fads I'm just showing
you some more data these are what eight
trials this is what this looks like sort
of okay and now we examine the inputs
then we used for inferred inputs here
for can be motivated because there is a
sort of the reach direction and then
there's the trial type that's our
there's the the trial type and there's
the perturbations and there's also some
LFP in there that's has this getting
sucked up okay so if we focus here the
inferred input now I've color coded this
perturb left is blue perturb right is
red this fourth dimension of the input
on the trial average definitely encodes
which way the trial is going to go right
and so I'm sorry I didn't tell you
something basic here this is the target
onset and then later on in time this
triangle is the perturbation onset and
so later on in time we see at the
triangle there's clear separation in
this first input dimension that dictates
what the perturbation should be and it
comes in at the right time and has is it
exists first off and it comes in at the
right time and it sort of separates by
condition okay so when you look at the
single trials the inputs are messy but
they separate and on single trials you
if you do a TC nice plot of that TC plot
of the little time segments around the
perturbation you can see the perturb
left and right and the unperturbed
trials here
so there's one tiny more segment one a
little more segment and I'm done
oscillations I think that's what lessons
right yep so here's a question I mean we
saw how manifold embeddings our real
neural data really seemed to be great
you know this is a yellow could you use
that same technique on your recurrent
networks generators to see if there is a
hidden amount of holder
sure absolutely so right now what we've
been doing is using techniques that were
sort of already derived used to sort of
practice in the literature such as JP CA
or whatnot but yeah in any technique
that's that's going to help identify
meaningful manifolds could be used for
the generator and on top of that we do
have the factors which is some version
of that
okay so coming back to the acceptance
phase of seeing oscillations in the data
here we have a reach and you see this
sort of beta like a 15 Hertz or so in
the preparatory period of the movement
and this is actually really well known
it was new to me but we all learn things
and so the the the spikes are
synchronized to the to the tops of the
lfp oscillation this is true in monkeys
and in humans so we wanted to study this
but you you might think that you don't
need single trials to do this actually
but you do because if there's any first
off oscillation is a very loose term
right I mean these things are wiggling
all over the place in terms of their
their frequency but on top of that even
if they were perfect oscillations if you
don't get the phase right you're just
gonna average everything out all right
so that's what we mean here and so let's
just show the data here's a single trial
again m1 and PMD this is much stronger
in NP MD and here's the local field
potential visualize so what we're doing
here is we're showing you this is on the
channels right so this is a Utah array
with the for the the for the two by two
channels and we're just aligning them
you see these very narrow political
lights in your rates right do these
correspond to something that Sonya drew
a long time ago called unitary events so
how these really kind of kind of
population spikes in sets of neurons
that go on almost together so what I
what I'm going to show you is that they
correlate tightly with lfp and beyond
that I don't think the way to think of
the mean the inferred firing rates are
the isn't aeneas rate spike but but it
with a post on across on generated be
not getting these spikes out so human
innovation of firing rate goes up like
crazy in such on this vertical line
right it seems almost I mean you know I
mean what worries me if I see this is
that compared to the firing rates these
rate changes are very fast and very
steep well they're definitely they're
definitely so first off they're
definitely there it's it's not on the
screen but we did controls it
how is this reflected in the data so
does this really mean that there are
subsets of salsa yes yes that's what it
means that the few wouldn't if you were
to sum over this vertical dimension it
would start to look a lot more like what
you're seeing there that's what it is
exactly what it say is yeah so it's
really there and we just don't really
focus on it okay so so what we what we
did here is we in black we correlated
the spikes with the LFP right and that
gives you here those Wiggles and then it
with L pads we took the inferred rates
from L Fez and we correlated them and
you can see these are just four
different channels channel 13 channel 19
what we exact they there's a very very
tight match which which means that when
you see a wiggle here it's actually
because it I should have said that the
multi unit array actually records the
lfp as well right so you can compare
those things and now when you shuffle
shuffle trials everything gets washed
out okay so I just want to point this is
sort of interesting caveat here which is
we couldn't do this without the inferred
inputs so that is to say the inferred
inputs are providing information to
these trials through time that that was
necessary to make these correspond this
correspondence of course with an RNN you
can fit anything but on the held out
trials do you have anything in any data
there anything to say and so what I take
this is is that even though you think of
an LFP is this really sort of simple
signal because it's low dimensional it's
actually really complicated in time and
so you need so what this argues is that
well what sort of the lore that said is
that these LPS are somehow involved or a
byproduct of communication between
different areas and so you can't
actually model it in the sense of
modeling it dynamically
this is a closer to 15 to 20 okay so I'm
done
so where we going it seems pretty
clear-cut you'd want to have a calcium
imaging model on this so that would
change the distribution instead of
having Poisson counts you would have
Gaussian or something applications to
brain machine interface seem pretty
clear-cut
I loved it's just like see what happens
if you had take a bunch of neural pixels
probes and you try to do this stitching
I mean that would be really super
interesting and and then finally
reconstructing dynamics across animals
right I think that it's also very
interesting and so thank you for your
time so yeah so my question is this is
very interesting and you could say that
the model isn't complicated but I mean
the stitching I think is very very
interesting but the question is a little
bit how do you think how does this how
do you interpret this as a computation
in this brain area and it almost feels
to me that behavior that you're studying
is too simple because you wouldn't want
really to show that all this longing
that you're doing in the artificial
network that you really learn the report
of interesting behaviors that are you
know I mean I my question is can you
somehow tie this to information
processing Kevin somehow say what does
it toss right so so what I would say
there is I so first let me start with a
caveat I made before I I think we're
building abstract models of real
dynamics and so I don't hold much hope
out for connectome Oh connectomics like
project I know yeah it's so so just
stating that having said that if you had
enough trials and enough varied
conditions and so forth then this is
going to learn that it's going to learn
that system so it will be a very
meaningful yet though abstract model of
the dynamics
on going in a particular region so the
question then becomes can a very
accurate abstract model of dynamics be a
useful scientific tool and I think it
can be I think you can ask questions
about for example perturbations right
you have these dynamics you well I
believe if I perturb in this dimension
then this type of dynamics should happen
if that holds up to be true then yeah so
there's a precedent here a dynamical
Systems Theory so you saw the Lorenz
attractor so what they not proven you
know that with this and with a simple
embedding in other words you just take
one variable and embed it into a value
of T versus value of t minus tau that
from that trajectory you can infer the
attractor it can infer some fundamental
dynamical property of a very complex
underlying system and so you know this
is potentially what you want to bring is
what you want to extract from going once
IQ yeah so this is the variational auto
encoder so it's a it's a non it's a
negative log likelihood loss with a
Poisson output distribution and then
there is a stochastic hidden layer right
that's the the codes and also the
inferred inputs near the end of the talk
and that those use the to back propagate
through those stochastic layers you use
the parameter Reaper ammeter is a ssin
trick whereby the stochasticity is
the difficulty of that is ameliorated so
i want to return to my question of what
is the minimum dimension which actually
makes sense and one way of testing it is
to keep out some of the neurons outside
of your model as some sort of a test
test test set and actually try to infer
that their behavior from the other near
so we did that and and at some point
this should collapse I mean and this
will give you some some some sense of a
minimum dimensionality of the problem so
you're saying that as I decrease the
number of as I decrease the number of
dimensions in the generator the fit to
the held out units should deteriorate
and that tells me so this should be some
sort of for me in this feat which should
tell you something about the true that
whether I can actually trust anything
you say I say and again it's very
closely related to the work we did in 95
96 is herbalists and some of my students
with a germans and and we actually had
you know very similar areas in monkeys
and we did it in the in the no-go fair
in the delay between the go and algal
phase affair of it's a delayed response
experiment and we actually found
wonderful state transitions and and the
way i trusted it then only when they
actually put cross validators on and l
held out since so so I take I take your
point about studying the dimensionality
with respect to held out neurons but
we've done a lot of controls here and I
don't know if I've convinced you but at
the very least I've convinced my so we
would just just to enumerate it
obviously cross validation for training
so everything is held out all the data
is shown is is held out data we did held
out conditions right we also did I
didn't show it but we did the held out
its so-called Coast smoothing the
problem is I didn't show that result
because it's really hard to know what
one bit of log-likelihood and I don't
even know I have no idea what that means
right but anyways we did that too so
here's the question about generalization
so you have data from the monkey doing
you know eight inside now if you had
additional data from the monkey just
move me his hand around right I mean not
necessarily in and out but you know
around do you think that your model
trained up on the in out could do the
kinematics for the more general that's a
great question so then I can't answer
your specific question but I can paint a
sort of one parameter family of answers
if you will if you have two different
data sets that are totally different and
they don't not much data associated with
either of them then the chance that an
Alf ads model trained on one of those
data sets has anything to say about the
other is essentially zero
now you move that forward to a scenario
where you have basically really
rigorously tested the behavior of let's
say the arm since that's what we're
talking about
you have weights and it goes up it goes
down it goes left and right then yes you
will that what that model should be
taken very seriously and I think this
comes to at the high level that these
deep networks are very good at
interpolation and not so hot at
extrapolation right and that's what
I'm curious about how the addition label
is work but if you gave at the center of
reaches but didn't say which reaches or
which target
oh yeah I'm sorry I should have said at
the beginning there were there were no
condition labels here no not any example
at all it's just pure auto auto encoding
of data so the models interesting
because you assume that there some
mechanism that generates this dynamic
and then you perturb right and you get
this you but you had a very different
data set there where panel is reaching
so you know it could be that if you
analyze the perturb data with just the
auto encoder right you also get
something out right that says left and
right that's not necessarily I'm just
wondering how do you how do you this
comes down to that it's an ill-defined
thing to try right so how do you reason
about it in a scenario where you like
that particular data set was almost
perfectly constructed to make the point
and if you're outside of that setting
then how do you actually trust something
so you could turn into just another
dynamic in the sort of center
outreaching that's right so the one so
in general the issue is I think unsolved
I don't have an answer for you in
practice there are things you can do to
feel more confident about it number one
is only have one or two inferred inputs
and then you know it can't describe
everything there is also regularization
pressure on that inferred input I didn't
go into it but there's an regularization
pressure to deliver no information it's
a KL penalty to an uninformative
Gaussian so that's all on there as well
but I take your broader point is how you
formulate a question
can you comment on the application to
BMI yeah sure
so the idea is that there's a I guess a
more recent line of thinking that if you
had a model of the dynamics of your
system then you would be able to use
that if you it's like a prior on i'm
you've being very informal here but it's
like a prior on what happens when you
actually go into a BMI mode so if you
could actually model that so right now
this may be more detailed right now the
the standard model is a common filter
that assumes that the that the
kinematics drives the spikes spiking
observations which is it's its flipped
it's wrong right the right I believe the
right way to do it is that the spikes
drive the kinematics and so now you have
to develop a model for those spikes and
that just from taking a few days of data
may not be very rich but if you had a
model like this for this somewhere but
if you had a richer model of the kingdom
excuse me of the neural dynamics that
would definitely inform the state model
in this in this basically non-linear
calming filter so you have data for
remote or motor cortex how are these
thinking about this control input so
could I mean if you for example would
model the dynamics in the promoter area
and you try to infer your controller
input in the motor area what you think
that your relationship or yeah it's a
good question could you could you use
those two basically if you have an input
and you have an ALP we haven't done it
it's it we should try something like
that and see what we can get yeah have
you tried that I've said of using spikes
using the L of pieces you have that then
just trying to do the whole you know
generator based on I'm trying to it's an
interesting finish it has been shown
that BCI can actually be you know
there's a lot of information errors
you've already shown that is in the
sense
might be telling you something a little
bit different from what others have
inferred from the spikes right but why
stop there
try the EEG now you're getting radical I
saw Fritz's okay this is this is but
talk about radical okay here's here's
somebody who has gone against the
received wisdom of a fifty year history
in the hippocampus saying that there is
no spatial organization that is all
basically the salt pepper right but he's
showing that nonetheless you can extract
information from this very crude
oscillations just the terms of the phase
shifts and phase differences that allow
you to do the decoding for positions so
there's actually a lot more information
there than we thought
right hello sure you absolutely and so
you know it's if it works it would be
unbelievably important the reason is
that you know putting electrodes in this
very invasive
that's our goodness if you can actually
extract more information from the EEG
that other people have them you know
that has a huge implication would be
that's that's hard work accessories
session stitching part yep you're
extracting like the common component
across multiple sessions so there must
be there's obviously a residual
component and I guess how do you think
of that in terms of like that
variability that's going on and it you
can sort of subtract that away or
somehow differentiate away from the
common part can you somehow relate that
to other behavioral variables that are
there changing from day to day or
so I think there were two ideas sort of
conjoined there right so to the the
variability of the trial is going to be
stuff in these two matrices and really
the powerful variability is that the
input matrix can determine how the
system gets driven right and that can be
arbitrarily powerful I mean you could
just these systems can learn if you have
s sessions that just learn s different
dynamics right so that could be
pathologically powerful so that's where
so they express its the initial
condition that would be expressed as the
code that is differentiating between
session and if you wanted now I guess
the other piece of this is that if you
wanted to try to study somehow non
stationarity for example learning or
drift in representation just like the
readout part that you're changing from
session to session and an input part
that's right yeah so I the way I see it
is you're the the actual the readout the
readout is true what you've measured is
changing right so you believe that
there's some underlying system that that
is low dimensional otherwise it's
hopeless anyways and one day you're
getting this particular random matrix
read out of it and another day to be
able to emphasize and recording from
different cells reporting for different
cells that's right so in this case these
are V probes where you actually take
them out and put them back in yeah yeah
but but you could still do the same
thing for Utah raids where you it's
chronic and then you hope that there and
there is shift I mean in BMI it's in an
enormous headache right so if you didn't
believe in course on spiking you could
have a mixture of faster processes
continue that
that and then that would be your
underlying model but yeah so I guess I
would I sort of agree in half so the
issue is if so yeah you could forget the
puss on output you could have some
biophysically do now you have to sort of
pick a window that seems to work on the
data that's right so there's a bin size
issue right so that but it could be that
it's just a mixture of a small handful
of processes with yeah ultimately a
better model so I guess there's a
philosophical point though which is I
believe I can identify a low dimensional
sort of smooth dynamics I have far in
fact I would bet against it with a lot
of money that I could actually identify
a dynamics we're buying pissed bidding
on spikes at each point you can always
fit it but will it will it generalize
right I mean the actual spike generation
process would require understanding an
enormous amount of detail but it would
require an understanding or some amount
of detail about the biological circuit
that is essentially prevented from us
right you've all right the rate of the
Poisson process isn't it that's right
yeah within some limits I guess Oh some
it's been limited signal yeah so there
are no so so with regards to time
constraints this is a deceivin that we
think of these dynamics is continuous
time this is a discrete set time system
so whatever the Nyquist rate of your
sampling is I've drawn a very then it's
anything it's not so yeah but so in
practice that won't be in what's going
on so so if you take your your D
dimensional factors each of which is a
function of time and so you could think
then of the system evolving in in those
coordinates at a uniform velocity right
so in some sense the factors are at
dynamical
and what what you've done is factorize
the complicated dynamical system into
this part that you're pulling out that
you're saying is session dependent or
something like that and this other part
that you're saying is is universal have
you thought of that decomposition of the
two dynamical systems because you're
you're kind of calling the factors these
matrices that you stick in the front
that go before the dynamical system but
really if I'm understanding what you're
saying really the factors are just
another dynamical system that you're
wandering through adding at a uniform
velocity and so you've factored that out
of the other dynamical system so the way
that the stitching works is that the
factors which are linear readout of the
generator so the generator generator
could be a million dimensional and
you're getting ten factors out of it
right they so that's those factors are
common across sessions that's the common
part and then what is no longer common
is then from those factors you have to
convert to the different actual
instantaneous rates that explain the
spikes on that also it's after you do
the factor that's right yeah that's
right
Andy Schwartz the did an experiment
which i think is very provocative you
know he's been doing is this decoding
for a long time and he's won has this
movie you see all the time of a woman
picking up the coffee cup for the first
time right no mother and so he had a
graduate student who's you know that
every every day they have to calibrate
it by the way because the dress agent
from the same ray and and one day one of
a student said well what if with if we
just randomized the twenty curves or
reverse them you know what do you know
let's let's try this out and of course
Andy said this is crazy because you're
throwing away all the hard-fought
detailed calibration that we have here
and sure enough when the monkey first
started out it wanted to have its arm go
this way and it went that way okay but
within the same session it recalibrated
itself so the monkey has some of the
brain of them in the motor cortex has
some adaptability so that it could
reinterpret you know the pattern it
leaves in order together his hand to the
right endpoint which which means that
the you know you have potentially the
ability here to look at learning but
it's it's really you know and it's
within one session so you don't have to
train for three months is that maybe
that might you know you said that
learning is impossible to study you in
monkeys because it takes a lot but if
this is a form of adaptability in the
motor cortex that you can study in one
session no I didn't say I said oh yeah
but in a case that that's another
dimension to study that can make I
suggest not I can see the room that you
guys can't see and I can tell people are
hungry so so why don't we have another
question and then close it out
scenario where probably the factors
would be the same so that type of
variability would show up in the codes
right it would show up in the initial
conditions and you could study that as a
function of day or or whatever right in
the new it would it would be some
summary of the drift even if it's not
mechanistic right okay said announcement
actually flips office just mailed us and
he is he fell ill and she cannot make it
so this means there's no more talks
anymore so this means they could now
write down the workshop we had a very
good discussion yesterday who is Bill
who believes it's raining in the earlier
who doesn't believe me who believes it's
not raining in the early afternoon today
exactly so whoever believes that who
wants to take a walk in the afternoon so
I would be up for it let's have a good
lunch now but maybe a tooth or deal so
we could we could meet and go up the
fire trail here and take a little a walk
and it's very tempting you
two-thirty but unfortunately this vines
down sooner than we expected I mean I
think we enjoyed it tremendously I hope
you as well thank you for all the
participation and all the talks and the
great atmosphere thank you
yeah